how's it goin I'm Matt from Bethesda and
we're here with Bethesda Game Studios
these guys have actually all worked on
the game the Fallout series for over 10
years together we've got the art
director Yvonne Paley lead producer Jeff
Gardner lead writer mo Pegler reuleaux
and you got us don't need a welcome or
you know who he is
yeah let's welcome him here's Todd
Howard the game director of fallout 4 so
the game was announced about two weeks
ago we showed it at the Showcase at e3
how are you guys coming along with the
game yeah great you know we're we're
where we need to be there's no there's a
lot to do yet we build really really big
games but you know we we make the games
we want to play and it's a blast to play
and we're really excited to to get it
out to everybody you know and the the
joke that you when you tell someone
you're a video game developer and oh you
play games all day you know no so three
and a half years you're not playing
games all day you're making them but now
it's sort of the the part of the project
where you are playing the game all day
trying to you know play it and test it
and fix it and get it where it's
supposed to be so I've played the game
probably 400 hours and I'm still finding
stuff that I haven't seen yet surprises
this is my favorite part of the project
is when it all starts coming together
it's clicking so much fun we're having a
blast I think that's one thing people
don't realize is they think like that we
know everything in the game but you
think like I would know everything in
the game I actually don't because there
we have a studio to work together for a
long time I know most of stuff in the
game but like I'll be playing the game
and run into something and be like who
built this what is this because it's so
big and then you know I think
collectively we all know everything in
the game but usually we'll ask each
other
what do you really think makes this feel
like a new fallout since the last one
you put out I think you know for for
every game we you step back and we look
at not as a sequel but like what makes
this fallout what is the essence will
fall
so you know this is something where we
step back and it's we're constantly
reinventing things and so this is a
whole you take whole new vision well I
grew up in Boston so for me that the
fall for it has an entirely different
meaning you know it has a very personal
connection to me it has a lot of
different tones through the world
because it can be very scary and then it
can get kind of at times almost b-movie
goofy but it all kind of works together
in Fallout 3 I think the people who live
in that world
are very cognizant of they're in this
destroyed world you know and so we
looked at that again and try to think
well what if you know it's not so much
about the past you know this is what
they know this is their world so there's
a little bit of you know you know
there's a post apocalypse in the
destroyed world but there's a glimmer of
hope sometimes too because there are
people that are getting on with their
lives and how do you look at that - and
how does that you know inform the
different stories in the world so even
when the team was finishing up Skyrim in
2011 you were actually actually putting
stuff in the world already what was that
like kind of being the first guy on the
front line yeah it was pretty cool I
mean I went straight into this game
right after a fallout 3 was finished
that's we've finished all the DLC so I'm
still very much fresh so I'm just having
to clean that project deciding like all
right what do we want to do this time
that's different we want to keep things
fresh we don't want to repeat ourselves
fallout 3 had a very distinct visual
style they can't you know you look at it
screenshot a video from it you can
easily identify it but this time we kind
of went back and sort of looked at it
and a lot of it for me was okay what is
fallout look back at Fallout 1 like what
are whether some of the vibes you want
to sort of carry over so we looked at
you know introducing more color more
variety in the world there isn't sort of
a a tonal grading over the whole game
visually this time you look back
original games the vibrancy of the vault
suit that called her blue the way it
pops on screen these color had a lot of
blue debates yeah very similar debates a
how how how blue is blue that isn't Mike
Green yeah yeah the exact color green
for for the interface all those little
detail so it you know it's going back
and trying to find what the essence of
the original game was and
trying to keep it fresh can I do
something you do you remember what the
first thing you did for the project was
yeah I think originally you know for one
of the things we want to do with this
game is is really look at doing a
post-apocalyptic City Boston trying to
doing a really dense realistic large
city this is one of gonna be one of our
most richly detailed and dense
environments that we've we've ever done
so a lot of it was for me looking at
doing a small vertical slice what's
what's that going to feel like
introducing new elements we haven't seen
much of before more verticality in
environments and we had a lot of
conversations early on too with with the
environment and the location to be
recognizable right and DC is easy you
know you've got the Washington Monument
the Capitol building and so that was
part of what we're talking about you
know what isn't visually about Boston
that stands out too that separates it
from another city you know red brick
streets and a lot of you know classic
architecture that sort of Beverly Park
that stuck out a lot yes anyway we get
the Fenway in there in the right way
yeah when did you guys kind of get to
the decision that was gonna be the next
fallout location we debated for a while
we had had some seeds and fallout 3 and
we felt that Boston was kind of the
right it's got the right mix of like
American history mixed with high-tech
it's very good for Fallout plus it
doesn't hurt that MO it grew up there so
you know his he could talk more about it
you know I remember the conversation
with it I remember the moment actually
when we decided the game would be in
Boston it was Todd in East Vaughn and I
in his funds office and they were
talking and I'm thinking in my head like
are they going towards Boston this one
here like we're all sort of talking
about don't want to oversell it looking
like I didn't want the game in Boston
and so we finally decided let's you know
set it in Boston and Todd just turns to
me and says I is that okay with you I'm
like all right no no we're talking yeah
as a developer as a designer you know
and you're making the game Boston they
call Boston America's Walking City you
know and so there's a lot you can you
you can fly into Logan Airport and you
go downtown Boston you can see a lot in
a very short amount of time and so I'm
walking around in the
I've gotten homesick you know I'm like
this is so this reminds me exactly like
oh this is what this thing my pouch yeah
my house is in the game destroyed Wow
single tear it's also a very visually
intriguing environment too because
Boston has so much character it's got a
very specific look to it all the red
brick and whatnot and introducing the
fall elements to that visually in terms
of like the high tech the disguise
papers that you know the more futurism
blending of futurism with sort of the
historical colonial quality to it that
was very exciting to try to figure that
out so you created a ton of work for
this I think we've got some footage of
actually the concept art that went into
creating all this so Todd I think you
you go into this that it's every every
little detail in the game is is
important even from every monitor in the
game you know I say that I think it's
hard for people who play our games to
you know wish they could be a fly on the
wall in the office sometimes and see
just how obsessive we get over all the
details you know and we're not showing
all the concept art here we just
possibly you know we can but those the
lights they're really art I really like
those images it's almost symbolic to
this like obsession with like what are
the labels on these blinky lights and I
like on every computer in this area
because someone you know we like people
be able to stick their noses in it and
so despite it being like I think a lot
of times our stuff maybe feels really
everything feels really grand but we're
also a first-person game now so we need
to hold up at both scales that you can
stick your nose in it and you know
credit to our artists they are they are
amazing our concert doors are fantastic
and and because of you know the unique
nature will fall out like everything has
to be designed every vehicle every prop
in the world the architecture it does so
much so much we have to draw it a cover
for artists to build them yeah you see a
fraction about it here
I almost think this video it may even do
a better job than the footage we put out
of showing you the different styles and
palettes of what you're gonna see in the
in the game world we actually go back to
some of these environments after we
built them paint them over again and
then redo them in the game just to make
sure it's everything's perfect the
lighting and the shadow and how
everything interchange in their place
early on there was there were one or two
concepts that you know I think the
artists rift on just caming up coming up
with I think like a city street and we
were like well could we actually do that
in the game and we had it wasn't the way
we built spaces before and we actually
ended up changing a process a little bit
to make some of these really doing
architecture like that destroyed showing
destruction in a different way the big
thing we do and this was tricky with
what you know East one was building
originally is that we have a lot more
non loading space because it's all
destroyed it's harder to do like here's
a big castle gate and you click it it's
like we wanted these really granulated
buildings and with the light coming
through it and so the concept artists
could draw really crazy stuff like that
and you know with the new consoles and
the memory and the tech were able to
build these things where it's it's a lot
more free-flowing particularly you know
downtown was the biggest struggle
technically to get going in the detail
level we wanted the building of
settlements and the weapon customization
that seems pretty crazy and ambitious
for you guys I think we have some
footage of that right here so did did a
heart fire play a big part into this
from Skyrim or was it just something you
wanted to do all along I wouldn't say we
do a little bit of this in all the games
we do so when we were when when hearth
fire was being made we knew we were you
know doing this but it wasn't I wouldn't
say one had anything to it the other
it's just this one is completely it's a
completely different animal so this
really became like we'd like to do it
can we even do it and I I think the the
inspirations are pretty clear here
things like Minecraft and other games
that that we like and that we could do
it really well in a world like fallout
and and you know I remember discussions
actually because Jeff and Todd and I are
our kids were playing Minecraft on the
same time so we would have these
discussions about like what are our kids
playing what are they creating and you
know and it's her area was another one
yeah where people will come to your you
know and one of our artists made that I
just thought it was so awesome
is if we got to put that in the video
like that was that's not he built that
and then you know set up all that you
can set up the wires and control them
one of the things we don't show cuz it's
you know could get in the video see he
made a music player too like you can
make things that play audio tunes and
then plug the terminal in and adjust the
pitch and so that's the visual
programming kind of being able to do
that or how's that work
yeah because we have terminals and
fallout we can kind of get away with
like pseudo scripting without you
getting in and modding and scripting
because you can build a terminal and
then access everything on it and so as
the artists and the other designer is
making new things they give them
properties and those properties will
feedback to the terminal and you can see
those so like you know we're it works
well in the game but we're more excited
to like get it out to everybody and then
see what see what they make with it so
you look at what people do with
Minecraft just with basic timers and
switches and redstone it's pretty
bonkers
so working on the project Jeff does it
feel like you're a parent or an overseer
making sure all this stuff's getting
done to HIPAA hit the release date in
some regards I have five children so
it's not nearly as difficult as that
honestly but one's enough for me I know
they're wonderful but the you know like
I said we are blessed to work with some
of the best professionals in this
industry we're still sort of a scrappy
team in a way you know we're just over a
hundred people not nearly as big as some
of the other studios so we're able to
really have great rapport on individual
bore with most you know all our
developers and really get like this
great I hate the word synergy but that's
what it is going between different
departments and we empower people to do
what they love when they come to our
work and they're really like you know
what what can you contribute today and
it's not like we hand them a task
or anything along those lines we find
surprises all the time the game and
those are generally for us on the best
things in the game like we've been
working together you know for ten years
on the fall shows right but that's
representative the company to like a lot
most of the people at Bethesda have been
there for a long time so we've worked a
lot of people most of the people on the
team we've been working with them for
years so you get to know them there's a
certain flow and energy and you know and
just you know how they work and how to
communicate effectively with them and it
did people see the end result of what we
do but we're coming to the office for
four years and we spend a lot of time
together and that's you know I think our
creative energies together everybody in
the team that really shows through in
the game